hı Hello Herkese merhaba arkadaşlar
sizlerden gelen yoğun istek üzerine
artık Almanca derslerimize başlıyoruz
bugünkü konumuz be gülüsün un perhaps
şeyden hazırsak hemen dersimize
başlayalım
Bu dersimizde neler öğreneceğiz hemen
Ben şuradan kalemimi alıyorum be gülüsün
un Ferah şeyden selamlaşma vedalaşma
kalıplarını öğreneceğiz forscht elin
tanışma kalıplarını öğreneceğiz ve en
son olarak da hal hatır sor mavi git
eskiye kalıbını öğreneceğiz o zaman
hemen devam edelim ve selamlaşma dan
başlayalım be gürültüsünün
selamlaşma kalıpları olarak
düşünebiliriz
Peki Almanca'da selamlaşmak için birden
fazla kalıp var ilk olarak her yerde
duyduğumuz Hello merhaba Z airvuz
merhaba demek Ama tek bir fark bayan
eyaletinde kullan bu guru skot Allah'ın
selamı üzerine olsun daha çok
Selamünaleyküm olarak kullanabiliriz ve
nerede kullanıyoruz özt arayış
Avusturya'da kullanılıyor Gut und Morgen
Günaydın gutin terk İyi günler gritty
yine iyi günler anlamına geliyor mu
yerel bir kullanın şu var et İsviçre'de
kullanılıyor bütün abin İyi akşamlar ve
gut en az İyi geceler bilsem süper olur
köşesi Almanya'nın kuzeyinde bütün
Morgan yerine daha çok moin kalıbı
kullanılır Güney Almanya'da ise bu kalıp
zerrus olarak değişiyor yerel bir
kullanım diye demiştik hemen devam
edelim ferapsida Uyan çüz görüşürüz Al
Filiz'in tekrar görüşmek üzere Görüşürüz
yine aslında aynı anlamlara geliyor a of
bir da hıren burada bir farklılık var
Evet Tekrar görüşmek üzere anlamına
geliyor ama telefonda konuşurken
konuşmamızı bu girdiğimizde afvi daha
örüyoruz biz bel ya da avrupal görüşmek
üzere Burada da bu kalıpta da yakın bir
zamandan bahsediyorsak Yani beş dakika
sonra 10 dakika sonra görüşecek sake Biz
Bella of byte diyebiliriz 5p yeter ya da
biz dan sonra görüşürüz Yani arada
Belirli bir zaman aralığı varsa bir saat
olabilir iki saat olabilir belki bir gün
olabilir yani bir zaman sonra görüşecek
Sen eğer biz şüphe ta ya da bizden
kullanıyoruz Biz Morgen Yarın görüşürüz
biz plaj Az sonra görüşürüz yine kısa
bir zaman aralığından bahsediyoruz şunun
tekno İyi günler Aslında daha çok güzel
günler Gününüz güzel geçsin anlamında
şılafgut iyi uykular bu tanaz iyi
geceler çal Hoşçakal maskot Kendine iyi
bak bunu da şöyle Bu araştırma
yapabiliriz tek
Kiriş İngilizce'den yola çıkarsak Mask
out beyazının görüşürüz görüşmek üzere
yine aslına bakarsanız tüm kalıplarımız
görüşürüz anlamına göre ufak kelime
farklılıklarıyla değişiyor Biz Sum
nehrin mal birdahaki sefere görüşürüz
aynı şöyle tart no hemen Konumuza devam
ediyoruz Evet artık selamlaştık
vedalaştık ama kendimizi tanıtmadan
hemen kendimizi tanıtmaya öğrenelim dış
for Stalin name is im for name e ile
isim yanağımı kullanabilirim ya da
forname kullanabilirim daha çok ön at
anlamına geliyor de nachnahme soyisim
bir diğer anlamıyla ise diğer familyanın
ama yine soyisim yani aile adımızda
salta yaş dev 14 ikamet yeri oturulan
yer değil Bu
memleket ya da köken diyebiliriz Nağme
hemen nasıl isim sorabiliriz
karşımızdakine Öncelikle bir bunu
öğrenelim viesta İnna M ismi nedir My
Name EST Tonguç Benim adım Tonguç Wie
heisst du adı ne eş heyse Tonguç Benim
adım Tonguç veya Best to Sen kimsin iş
bin Tonguç farkettiyseniz üç farklı
soruyla ben karşımdaki kişiye isminin
sora biliyorum yine cevaplarını da
soruya yönelik olarak veriyorum burada
gördüğümüz üç farklı isim sorma kalıbı
samimi bir anlatım içeriyor diğer bir
değişti formel dediğimizde resmi ben
Karşımda bir Müdürüm bir öğretmenin
varsa ve esterna mı Senin ismin nedir
diye soramam Ne yapmam gerekiyor ve en
iyi Namet Sizin isminiz nedir Bir Ya sen
zil Sizin isminiz nedir veya cinsi Siz
kimsiniz ya da kısaca kimsiniz hemen
devam ediyoruz Aynı sana ne demiştik yaş
biraz Space to Kaç yaşındasın eş
1020 20'nin Almanca'sı ne Peki stranding
eş Ben svans iş Yare at ben 20
yaşındayım Peki bir öğretmenime yaşını
sormak istiyorum çok merak ettim aklıma
takıldı geceleri uyuyamıyorum farmın
resmi bir şekilde sormam lazım ve en
sinsi kaç yaşındasınız
Eşkin Price eşyaları at Ben 30
yaşındayım bakın sorularım samimi ve
resmi olarak ikiye ayrılıyor ama
cevapların aynı aynı kalıbı kullanıyorum
ashvane Trend işi ara bedura ise
şiyare alt hemen devam ediyoruz bon ord
bu
wohnort ikamet yeri yada oturulan yer
vagon to nerede oturuyorsun bakın dusen
senle bir kullanım Yani bir samimiyet
içeriyor Peki resmi olarak nasıl
soracağım Volvo'nun izi Nerede
oturuyorsunuz cevap verirken ise iki
soruya da aynı kalıbı kullanıyorum
işverene en İstanbul İstanbul'da
oturuyorum ilk bu ne en
istanbulin aynı İngilizce'deki içinde
anlamını veriyor ama daha çok een da de
olarak kullanıyoruz wallops to nerede
yaşıyorsun Böyle benzin Nerede
yaşıyorsunuz yine voleyb su derken
samimi bir kullanım voleybol zi derken
resmi bir kullanın bu onun fiiline
demiştik ikamet etmek ya da oturulan
yerler ve kilise yaşamak anlamına
geliyor peki Her iki soruma da nasıl
cevap vereceğim aynı kalıp cümle ile
cevap veriyorum eşli beğenin
İstanbul Ben İstanbul'da yaşıyorum
işli biri yine stanbul Evet artık
oturduğunuz yeri de söyleye bildiğimize
göre hemen her kum memleketimizi
söyleyelim tanışırken ne yapıyoruz
Memleketin neresi diye soruyor ilk merak
ettiğimiz konu her zaman bu oluyor ve
her komsu nerelisin ya da nereden
geliyorsun Komün fiili gelmek Nereden
geliyorsun Ama biz kısaca kullanıyoruz
Nerelisin bu herko müziği nerelisiniz ne
demiştik ve her comunes i resmi bir
kullanım bu her Kontu samimi bir
kullanın iki sorumlu ayırdığım ama
cevabım yine aynı her iki soruyor da
aynı cevabı veriyorum iş komedi bu
Bursa Ben Bursalıyım ya da
Bursa'dan
geliyorum benden anlamında iş komme aus
Bursa hemen devam ediyoruz Haydi
birlikte pekiştireç işte demiş fa
kendimi tanıtıyorum Hello merhaba iş
haysy Tonguç Yaşar da nasıl
söyleyebilirim iş bir Tonguç Benim adım
Tonguç ben tongucu ashbee enfance seni
arar Ben 15 yaşındayım iş Kome Ağustos
İstanbul Ben İstanbul'dan geliyorum iş
bu ne en İzmir ben İzmir'de oturuyorum
işleye Bean İzmir şimdi her iki soruda
da bunun Veli bunda da aslında nerede
oturduğumu
Ben diyorum yani iş bunu iniz mirişli
bin İzmir İzmir'de oturuyorum İzmir'de
yaşıyorum Böylelikle tüm öğrendiğim
kalıp sorulara bu cevapları verdiğimde
2-3 dakika boyunca kendimi tanıtabilirim
ve bir diyalog oluşturabilirim hemen
devam ediyoruz tanıştığımıza memnun
muyuz Almanca'da Tanıştığıma memnun
oldum demenin birden fazla yolu var şu
an değişken suların Seni tanıdığıma
memnun oldum Seni tanımak güzel Freud
tüm işe şuraya yemiş xayah aprol
gördüğünüz gibi dört tane kalıbım var ve
karşılığında diyeceğim ki ben de çok
memnun oldum Ben de seni tanıdığıma
memnun oldum mişa oh Ben de iş program
iş av Ben de tanıştığıma çok memnun
oldum
Ama genel olarak mietshaus diyerek
kısaca tanıştığımıza memnun olduğumuzu
söyleyebiliriz Evet Tanıştığımıza memnun
oldum saat artık devam edelim hal hatır
sor mavi ki testi ya kalıbı nasılsın
vites diyor We git diye bakın Enes hemen
burada kısaltmayı uğramış ve tamamen
kısaltmak istersem We Get ne yapıyorum
samimi bir diyalog oluşturacak sameer
ben bu üç kalıptan birini kullanıyorum
Ama genellikle wingates olarak kısa
kalıbı kullanabiliriz Peki resmi olarak
nasıl soracağım Bir öğretmenime bir iş
arkadaşıma nasıl nasılsın demem
gerekiyor
vitesinin Nasılsınız vitesinin Her iki
soruda da cevabın Yine Aynı şekilde Eski
gitmiyor kalıp olarak düşünüyoruz ya da
mi ya git
eskitmeye good Ben iyiyim ya da Miyagi
test zaman Ama ben çok iyiyim Peki
bilsem süper olur köşesi basit laws
neler oluyor al istila Her şey yolunda
mı was caps Noel de var ne yok Durumlar
nasıl daha çok Bu kalıplar Aslında
arkadaş ortamında kullanılıyor ve son
olarak davas kitap ne haber Ne habersin
nasılsın gibi Evet artık tanıştık hal
hatır sorduk devam ediyoruz Peki bir
arkadaşımız bize nasılsın diye sordu ve
Bende farklı bir cevap vermek istiyorum
Sadece good diyemem Z'ye good çok iyi
tarz upa buneba Prima fantastisch burada
gördüğümüz hepsi
harikayım anlamında kullanıyoruz zor la
la la Zozo eski tutmaya Burada da idare
eder
A öyle böyle şöyle böyle şeklinde cevap
veriyoruz ve son olarak da k ama
hissetmiyoruz ve me So good Hiç iyi
değilim shalash kötü Z yaşlı ve çok
kötüyüm berbatım şeklinde kullanıyoruz
Peki bir git esdia
nasılsın eski etmiyor süreçte çok
kötüyüm eski etmeye tall harikayım
eskitme buneba süperim Evet artık
tanıştık memnun olduk nasılsın sorusuna
da harika bir şekilde cevap verdiğimize
göre devam edelim ve birlikte pekiştireç
bilgi testi ya bir getezin vites diye
kalıbımız neydi samimi bir kullanım the
week etsin en resmi bir kullanımda
benden yaşça büyük birisi Ne sordum ya
da öğretmenim Yada iş arkadaşım ya da
patronuma sorduğunda We get in kalıbını
kullanıyorum Peki cevap olarak denk bu
eski gitmeye ganz khoudia
buradaki unut ya da nedir Ne sogut eş
Ben müdür Uni ne Hiç iyi değilim
yorgunum mü de
yorgun Peki buradaki un iğnedir Hemen
geliyorum kurt kısaca Zehra Guddi ya
diyebilirim ALES Goodbye dia's uzun in
Yani ben bana nasılsın diye sorulduğunda
uzun bir cümle söylememe gerek yok Zehra
gudiya samimi bir kullanım
ALES Goodbye Dia Her şey yolunda peki
senden yine samimi bir kullanım dozu Uni
yine bakın resmi kalıbının içinde yine
aynı şekilde Burada da görüyorum
zozotown iğne öyle böyle Sizden ne haber
siz nasılsınız gibi ne sogut eşb Evet Uu
ön dediğimde de uzun kalıbı kullanıyorum
Evet ilk Dersimiz bitti birlikte
pekiştirdi ve artık ödülü sorumuza
geçelim bu laptu nerede yaşıyorsun
yorumları nerede yaşadığınızı yazmayı
unutmayın Bizi nereden izliyorsunuz çok
merak ediyorum Kendinize iyi bakın Bir
sonraki derste görüşmek üzere hoşçakalın
o
[Müzik]